welcome to this video playing gear econ
from France wonder why doesn't the FM
just doesn't have a title but some
surprising okay I played him before it
is the guy he takes on f3 with them with
the pawn and they always have problems I
think here Bishop c5 is the main move
anyway but i cannot i really have
problems due to remember what is
happening i think d5 now i only recently
looked at this not in much detail i must
admit but I just studied it a bit
damn blood what taking them okay
864 really hmm I've got to two pawns
them two points down the others will get
very sharp very quickly because i'm
going to play Bishop g4 and I'm going to
sacrifice him probably let's see Bishop
g4 f3 mighty fall business assistant
this is this working and I'm probably
not Bishop g4 f3
yeah okay come on not not not so much
time here I keep it simple I mean this
leads to a position where I probably
have a decent compensation and he's
already one minute on the clock probably
castles and details deform and Bishop g4
first him I then that's 95 that's not
really good okay so let's just take yeah
the compensation is some not no I don't
I don't don't know exactly if it is
sufficient but there is some
compensation at least due to the bishops
and the development
ok Carrie jump probably d3 I don't
really see how it should get his pieces
out on d3 either i can at least capture
if I'm not if I don't find anything
better then he has some big poor 93 yeah
probably the only move hmm
jump Mancha let's let's take it and what
now should be three coming I don't know
really yeah it's a position where I have
some compensation but it's not so so
easy to to say what is the the best
possible way to play it some more more
of a positional compensation it's not
like I have any direct tactics going for
me Bishop f5 or Bishop c 6 mm I like
Bishop c6 somehow looks like a good
square
yeah I've played this guy before I have
a very bad score usually out of very
good positions but he is a very good
technical player very resourceful if it
takes h6 now though I have Queen g6 yeah
that's very good for me to bishops for
nothing after I got the porn back
okay come keep it simple just keep it
simple I one simply wants to play Bishop
deform to get part of my bishops okay
now probably will manage okay a bishop
Jeff bishop I can take here and Bishop
b5 maybe okay let's let's play quickly
check check
one minute okay check
now my king is very active yeah that's
the type of position where let's say
white can only be saved by the bell it's
a very nice don't see anything better
really I came let's try to get the porn
cm if you place night at five I will
take it
good defense time warning
check check check check check no no no
wrong ah what why did I allow him to
take I really could have one on time
here this is acid isn't it wrong I think
it's at all right or this now this is
what's wrong it's a super funny okay
yeah I had one second a shame a shame
relieve this this game but ok the time I
was always a bit bit behind on the clock
and it was always a bit tricky this was
not the I should just take here it's
much easier I wanted to gain even more
space but this always gives him some
counter play against against the tool
against the two pawns yeah it was it was
really ok I played it well with with
this a slow time always keeping a
substantial advantage and that'sthat's
really a really a strange move I think
94 I never saw that one I mean okay i
can i can also take here I wasn't sure
though
an IG for is good this I can do this I
can do casal screen edge for losing
immediately so we must play this check
and this is not exactly great mmm
interesting just back here now yeah it's
not it's not entirely clear even this is
this kind of this kind of line ah very
complicated okay thanks for watching